America freed the slaves and paid their owners instead, explained like your five.
Step 1.
It is April, 1862.
The Civil War is already underway, but slavery is still legal inside Washington, D.C. itself,
the nation's own capital.
Congress passes a law to end it there, before the rest of the country.
Lincoln signs it.
Step 2.
But here's the twist.
The government doesn't just declare people free.
It sets up a board of commissioners and tells slave owners loyal to the Union to file a
petition, almost like an insurance claim, for their loss of property.
For every enslaved person freed, the government pays their former owner up to $300.
Step 3.
Over the next nine months, the board approves 930 of these petitions, freeing nearly 3,000
people.
The formerly enslaved people themselves get nothing from this fund.
No payment, no land, no compensation for their years of labor.
The law even offers owners a bonus, up to $100 per person, if the freed person agrees
to emigrate out of the country entirely.
Step 4.
As strange as this sounds, America is actually late to this idea, and small scale compared
to what came before it.
Britain had already done the same thing 30 years earlier, in 1833, except at a vastly
bigger scale.
20 million pounds paid to British slave owners, worth roughly 40% of the entire government's
annual budget that year.
Step 5.
That British debt was so large it had to be rolled into government bonds.
British taxpayers, people with zero connection to slavery, kept quietly paying it off for
generations.
The loan wasn't fully settled until 2015, meaning some people alive today, filing their
taxes in Britain, were still helping pay off slave owners long after slavery itself had
become ancient history.
And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers.
Addictive, smart, surprisingly fun.
Try it now and become the most intelligent person in the room.